[Music]
creating a champion is an
absolutely amazing piece of literature
also known as masterworks if you are in
the land of the rising sun
if you thought breath of the wild lacked
story and explanation well
this book explains quite some stuff the
game itself refused to communicate to us
directly
it was released to celebrate the 30th
anniversary of the zelda series
and focuses solely on breath of the wild
it was published on december 15 2017 in
japan and november
20th 2018 in the west almost a full year
later
and who can blame them just look at the
size of it if you were one of the lucky
few to get one of the limited editions
the book came with all kinds of goodies
like a glass replica of a spirit orb a
calamity ganon tapestry
additional artwork and or four glass
orbs with the divine beast symbols on
them just to name a few
since its release this book has been a
great source of information for zelda
theorists and its canonicity unlike
other works like hyrule astoria has
largely been
accepted by fans it's basically a big
compilation of official artwork concept
art development history
additional lore and interviews with
different members of the zelda team
though to clarify the book
wasn't written by the zelda team itself
as you can imagine
they probably had better things to do
the book was compiled by nintendo dream
a japanese gaming magazine
akin to nintendo power but still up and
running and localized for
english-speaking
audiences by dark horse comics of course
the devs did play a big role in giving
shape to the overall book
and i'm sure they were responsible for
giving the green light to publish
however these are still second-hand
writings and with a book this size not
to mention possible translation errors
there are bound to be mistakes or at the
very least inconsistencies which seem to
clash with what we see in game
this video is focused on the english
translation of the book since well
first of all i don't read japanese and
second
actually i'm european but the large
majority of my audience is from the us
so i'm just going to pretend like i'm
one of you
go red sox it's a baseball team
what the red sox are a baseball team
oh anyway most zelda theories found on
youtube
are in english and thus based on that
version so some mistakes i point out
might not apply to the original
also keep in mind that even if a piece
of information contradicts the game that
doesn't automatically mean the book is
wrong
maybe the writers of the game's story
simply changed their mind about
something and altered it afterwards
who knows so in no particular order here
are 5 mistakes slash
inconsistencies in creating a champion
the prophecy is one of the most
well-known aspects in regards to the
backstory of breath of the wild
and one of the first big pieces of
expose link receives from king rome
before being let loose upon hyrule after
the great plateau section
a mysterious individual informed the
royal family of ganon's looming return
10 years before it actually happened
which set into motion all the events
leading up to the calamity such as the
large-scale excavations to find the
ancient chica relics zelda's training
and other preparations to deal with
ganon
the identity of this mystery person only
referred to as the fortune teller is
never revealed as according to creating
a champion all records of this person
were lost the book also states that
whoever this individual was
he or she must have been a trusted aide
or a high-ranking official since the
king took the prediction
very seriously however seemingly out of
nowhere the book also suggests that the
fortune teller
might have been the queen of hyrule who
died shortly after the prophecy came to
be
this suggestion clashes with the
information we are presented in the game
itself
the fortune teller is never referred to
directly in cutscenes
but there are two instances where this
prophet is mentioned
that being in zelda's diary and king
rome's journal
in both cases the wording doesn't
indicate that this person was the queen
on the contrary it seems to point in the
opposite being true
here are the two parts which mention the
fortune teller notice how in both
instances the two refer to this person
as simply
the fortune teller not only that but
king rome actually mentions the queen
just one page later
stating my queen has left this world
remember
these are private diaries meant for only
their eyes to see
there is no way that king rome would
refer to his own wife in such a way
only to call her my queen one page later
neither would zelda who was heavily
impacted by the death of her mother
referred to her
in such a casual manner if this was
supposed to hint at the queen being the
fortune teller then the game did a
terrible job at it or as i suspect i
think the writer of this section of the
book
may have taken some creative liberty and
inserted his or her own suggestion
which as i just demonstrated the
evidence seems to debunk
making it almost feel like a red herring
i don't believe that to be the case but
i do think that whoever wrote this down
might have not considered the evidence
against it
this is something i picked up on while i
was doing research for my calamity video
creating a champion states that the la
neru promenade also known as the
spider's nest
was destroyed during the great calamity
this area is actually where this
cutscene takes place
where the champions and zelda first
discover ganon's return
and indeed when we visit this location
in game we can see that the place is
devastated
but they forgot to add this location in
several maps which show all the affected
areas which were impacted by the
guardians
there are several instances of this map
being used in particular this one which
shows the defense of akala citadel and
fortateno princess zelda's journey and
this
map which shows the evacuation routes
during the event notice how in all
instances the promenade is not
highlighted in red
this is probably just a simple oversight
by whoever made this map
but still a pretty significant one since
all the other affected areas
are spot on
lake illuminae is a small and shallow
lake located in the west of the map and
north of the gerudo highlands right at
the foot of this massive mountain range
it's surrounded by trees and vegetation
almost like a little oasis
several wooden houses can be found here
indicating that this was a small
secluded settlement
the houses themselves are of the exact
same type as the ones we find in other
hylian settlements across the map
such as kaponga village and daea village
this little settlement
is completely absent from the book it's
not listed amongst destroyed settlements
and never even referred to
anywhere now you might say well it was
probably not significant enough to be
named which
is fair however not only is it not named
it's also absent from this map
which shows all the locations the
hylians used to inhabit before the
calamity
this map is very precise listing other
nameless settlements and even the
smallest singular buildings we can find
so why was lake illuminy completely
forgotten about
another argument could be that lake
illumini was already abandoned before
the great calamity but this too
doesn't really add up first off the
buildings are in the same state of decay
as all the other villages
and the damage to the houses also
matches that of the guardian's
ferociousness
secondly this area was actually within
the affected area
the maps i showed you before are
incomplete and only show a fraction of
the total map
but there is a complete version to be
found right above the evacuation map
it's very small but as you can see the
settlement was indeed inside the radius
of the guardian's destruction
poor lake illuminy not only were they
living far away from any living soul
isolated from the rest of the world with
no help coming but even creating a
champion
completely forgot about their existence
it is time for the zonai our favorite
unknown mystery tribe
as you know the game itself barely
reveals anything about them
aside from the name of their most
prominent ruins and the barbarian armor
set but here comes creating a champion
to the rescue
although the book doesn't reveal much
about their actual identity
it does elaborate on a few things about
their architecture their traits and
symbols and
where the idea of including them came
from in the first place
additionally on one of the very last
pages right before the closing words we
find this map
of ruins of times unknown here we find
various different ruins highlighted in
either green or yellow
green being marked as zona ruins and
yellow as ancient highland ruins at
first glance everything
seems to be in order we got the zona
ruins themselves
thundra plateau typhlo runes and the
lomae labyrinths which
may or may not be of zonai origin as
well though that one is up for debate
there are however a total of four
locations which are just
flat out mistakes they are very small
and thus
easily overlooked two in akala one in
upland zorana and one just south of rito
village
when we actually visit these places it
immediately becomes obvious that these
are not
zonai ruins the architecture doesn't
match that of the others
they are in fact ancient hylian ruins
and this one in upland zorrana
isn't even ancient hylian but modern
hylian as it is identical to that of the
other garrisons found across
hyrule the reason we know these are
ancient hylian and not
zonai is because there are two other
sites which have
architecture matching that of these
mistaken zonai ruins
namely the ones in tor and wetland and
more prominently the ancient columns
as you can see there's no mistaking that
these are identical to the others and in
the case of this one close to wrist
peninsula there's actually another
similar ruin located right down the hill
and that one
is actually marked as an ancient hylian
ruin
weird
on the day of the great calamity one of
the small victories that took place
beside
zelda sacrificing herself to seal ganon
was the miracle at fort hatteno
this too was zelda's doing and combined
with the effort of link and the ford's
militia the guardians were stopped in
their tracks preventing them access to
east necluda which kept tatenu village
out of harm's way
if you want to know more about this
event check out celtics video about that
one as
i don't have time to explain it in
detail if we are to believe what is told
to us both in game and from creating a
champion
the guardians never entered east necluda
because of this valiant effort and again
the map i showed you before which shows
all the affected areas
indeed shows that the guardians never
made it past fort hateno
but then how do we explain this there's
a total of two modern hylene ruins found
beyond the fort hattano border
and similar to lake illumini these show
signs of the same type of destruction
as all the other modern hylene ruins in
fact we find several identical ruins
right in front of fort ateno on the
deserted battlefield
now again you might say maybe these were
abandoned and destroyed before the
calamity
but then why are they highlighted on
this map which shows the locations the
hylians inhabited right before the great
calamity
this clearly indicates that they were
occupied before the disaster took place
in this case there's two
possibilities to explain this mistake
either the book is wrong and some
guardians did still manage to get
through after zelda and link left the
battlefield or before they arrived which
is possible but then again there are no
destroyed or
live guardians found anywhere in the
fields of east necluda
or the game is wrong and the world
designer simply made a mistake by
putting these ruins here
or maybe i'm wrong and there's a
plausible explanation for these ruins
this picture of link no real reason
i just think it was a mistake to include
it get it
away from me thanks a lot for watching
guys
let me know in the comments what you
think about these mistakes and
inconsistencies
perhaps like i said before i'm the one
who made a mistake and
falsely accused this poor book be sure
to let me know
as always a huge thanks to all of my
patreons and to
kuru tama who is my newest addition to
this list of
amazing supporters i will see you all
next week
this is don signing off and have a good
[Music]
one
you